[Music]
all right welcome everyone we are super
excited today to talk about the latest
Innovation from Google kubernetes engine
this will help our
customers increase velocity for multiple
developer teams it will help securely
run business critical workloads and
lower total cost ownership today I'll be
joined by vul mapara he's a fellow and
Sr leader from Equifax anaban sen Gupta
he's GK engineering and lisen GK product
management so kubernetes and containers
are increasingly popular among
Enterprise customers to deploy their
business critical
workloads what we are finding from
Gartner is that more than 90% of
Enterprise customers will will have
production applications running on
containers by
2027 C's vendors will be deploying their
software on containers more than about
60% 67% of them what this means is that
the adoption of containers is increasing
significantly right and we want to help
our
customers on this journey to adopt
containers and deploy them as widely as
they
want so what kind of applications bus
curricle applications are they running
we see them running everything from the
latest AIML workloads we see them
running a lot of their databases
stateful workload we seeing tons of
applications that fundamentally is
changing their business uh models so
let's talk about Ulta beauty Ulta beauty
took their legacy e-commerce platform
modernized it so they can deliver the
digital store of the future they are
fundamentally read looking at how they
can give a brand new experience to their
customers on Google kubernetes engine
eax they are using gke for their data
fabric they ingest over 250 billion data
points in process them and they've
generated over $2 billion in Revenue we
will be sharing a lot more about how GK
is transforming Equifax
business so what are we hearing from our
customers right as a container adoption
grows they're seeing more and more
complexity uh for scale what they really
want is how do I simplify or reduce
complexity
as the scale grows for containers number
two they're wanting to increase velocity
for their Dev team specifically how can
I give my Dev teams on demand
self-service access to container
environments while enforcing uniform
guard rails always whether they're
security governance or
compliance next customers consistently
bring up challenges or concerns around
security related to container
management 67% of customers identify
that container security is one of the
reasons why Innovation slows down or has
a significant impact on their business
model 35% of the time that's actually
because of the security tooling that
they are
using the third Talent there is a big
challenge trying to get the right talent
to adop containers at scale and this is
really help this is really a big
friction point for Enterprises globally
to deploy containers at scale across the
board so we are committed to helping our
containers adopt containers to the
extent they want help them support every
team every
workload and deploy them anywhere
without added complexity or
cost today I'm very excited to talk
about GK Enterprise the next evolution
of containers to help customers number
one increase velocity reduce risk and
lower total cost of ownership so how are
we doing this right so the first one we
think we can increase velocity for our
de development teams by fundamentally
changing the Paradigm go from per
cluster management to per team
management help our teams completely on
board very quickly as well as get the
right uh as well as get the right uh
visibility on the cost and performance
number two use built-in security for by
default secur by default Security in the
entire container stack everything from
platform clusters to
workloads number three how do we help
reduce uh the overall total Lo cost of
ownership by delivering a fully managed
container platform from Google that runs
everywhere right get away from get help
our teams focus more on building the
applications and delivering Innovation
versus building and maintaining the
technology stack that they
have
we are delivering lots of new
applications uh lots of new
capabilities uh as part of GK Enterprise
the first one is how do we help treat
multiple clusters as a single
entity right what this means is that now
platform admins can deploy default set
of policies whether they are security
policies compliance policies governance
policies uniformly this eliminates the
snowflake clusters it's a big pain point
that we continue to hear from our
customers right number two I'm really
excited to talk about the new innovation
we're bringing with teams with teams
what customers can do is you can create
and give access to your individual teams
access to Fleet of clusters right this
way you they can now each team can focus
on their container space with the right
guardrails that the admin has set up
we'll talk a lot more about how that's
going to transform what we looking at
third built in Security on by default we
want to make sure that every workload
every environment that they deliver is
always secure to start
with next is to get visibility per team
and uh per Fleet at Cost level at
performance level at um security
compliance concerns this allows our
customers to quickly get to the meantime
to resolution whether it's on the
performance side cost side or security
or governance
side
so how do we make this simple how does
this look in the real world right very
simple what we've done number one is
we've integrated all of GK capabilities
right into GK console it's a single
click away to start and test all the new
capabilities that we are talking
about as soon as you do
that a new screen comes up do you want
which features do you want to deploy
across the fleet of clusters that you
have you can take your security posture
capabilities deploy them across the
entire fleet you can also deploy policy
controller for your governance
capabilities for your compliance
capabilities across the entire field
Fleet of clusters you can also enable
service mesh across the entire fleet of
clusters I shared this with our customer
one of the customers earlier today and
they're like oh my God you can actually
deploy a fleet a service Mission across
the entire fleet that's amazing we've
simplified this significantly for our
customers including config delivery so
you get that consistency across the
board once you do that you get
visibility at a fleet level all your
governance violations that you might see
concerns you might see all your um
security vition that you might see all
the compliance violations you might see
you can see Fleet efficiency what
percent is being
used once you do that now that you've
got your Fleet managed how do I start
bringing different teams into it this is
what we are really excited about right
this is the transformation we talking
about per cluster to per
team what once you define a fleet you
can now Define a set of scope for your
team and you can do that at a name Space
level or a set of name spaces you you
can do this once you do this you can
start deploying some really cool
features right the first one we are
really uh deploying out is a roll out
upgrades you can now start rolling out
upgrades by team for your clusters
versus all the Clusters at the same time
really takes away the toil and reduces
the risk that your team might run into
number two you can now Define policies
at A Team level so while you have a
policy at the full Fleet level you can
then say for this particular team I want
some additional policies that I want to
put in place whether they are governance
policies security policies compliance
policies and then you can actually start
seeing violations against those that
makes it a lot more easier for you to
troubleshoot what's happening right and
cost cost cost right like how do I
understand what's the utilization what's
my cost by team how do I get that
visibility so that we are not surprised
and so you can start getting that
visibility by team as
well once you do this one of the new
capabilities we are delivering here is
the application Level security or
posture
right we've in the past we've delivered
platform Lal security last year we
unveiled GK posture for cluster security
this is looking at the application L
security for the container runtime
fantastic new capability that's going to
be G8 built in always on by
default and so if I take a step back and
take a look at all the capabilities we
are delivering right we only talk about
the new stuff from a customer
perspective what you're looking at is
now I can treat all my clusters as a
single entity with the fleet I can
create team space so I can M manage by
teams right number two you get full
security and governance across Fleet
across teams or by cluster you can get
service mesh at a fleet level at a
cluster level you can get cost and
performance visibility at a fleet level
at a cluster level at A Team level you
can get full get Ops driven
configuration management so you can
manage your drift management eliminate
drift management as well across your
Fleet Le across your teams and across a
cluster right this runs everywhere
meaning that you can we start from gcp
it extends into multicloud aw Azure as
well as extends onto on
Prem right it's a fully unified console
meaning one screen for all your
workloads no matter where they are and
we are using the leading OSS components
so that way you always have the
optionality that you're looking
for so what are we hearing from from our
customers number one platform teams who
are using GK Enterprise today they
reported 45% increase in productivity
that's fantastic right number two people
are spending less time waiting for their
infrastructure to show up that's
increasing their uh speed of deployment
by
73% right velocity that's something that
customers really want especially with
all the new innovation that's happening
with
AIML and people are getting much greater
visibility into their compliance and
security violations and resolution time
has decreased by
91% so fantastic set of capabilities as
part of GK Enterprise we think this is
the next Evolution for where containers
are headed and we are very happy that we
are first to Market with this right with
that I'm going to ask people to come and
talk about his journey with GK
[Applause]
Enterprise
right sorry for my 101 mistake learning
I used to be on the other side I happen
to be this side so here I am thank you
all for coming out for the session so
I'm vipp mapara I'm working with aquafax
data fabric decision science uh as an
SRE and leading platform engineering
team today I'm here to share some
insight about our Equifax cloud and the
Google Journey that we have taken
on little about Equifax so Equifax is a
global data analytics and technology
company we play an essential role in the
economy and help people live their
financial best how do we do that right
so we'll talk about a little bit more
detail but let's understand little more
mechanics so we have pedabytes of data
sitting in our aquax assets and also we
have 800 people million people that we
track that data and their financial what
we call all my payments
globally that said we have 700 data
scientists working globally crunching
that data and bringing an innovation and
the product that helps our customer we
are Cloud native we invested 1.5 billion
plus dollars to innovate our technology
stack for our next generation of
growth let's understand a little bit how
do we do that and what's our expertise a
lot of time people know us as a credit
report or credit risk agency but we a
little more than that we play into a lot
more Industries across the board we play
into Financial Services we play into
mortgage we play into Automotive
Communications health care insurance so
you name it so we are playing across all
these industries across the globe our
unique blend of data helps us to fuel
that Innovation into our products we
help our customers our banks our
financial institutions to make smarter
decisions with our Innovative product
and deliver outcome which helps people
live their financial best so that's what
we do think about it when you apply for
a job you apply for a mortgage loan you
apply for an auto loan you are
leveraging our systems all the way
around also while I'm here it gives me
immense Pride that Equifax has been
recipient of Google custom of the year
three times in a
row that's a commendable recog
recognition to pull off at the pace we
have done the Innovation and our
multi-year investment from our
leadership $ 1.5 billion helps us to
achieve this kind of scale to give you a
little more deeper Insight 1500 plus
applications has been rebuilt we have
rebuilt over 50 plus databases across
the globe so that is a sheer volume of
innovation that we have done in last few
years and that's what got us to this so
speaking of that let me take you a
little more deeper into the Equifax
Cloud journey and how we landed on the
GK Enterprise as our natural fit so
hopefully with this you get you're
staying with me and you're connecting
with me so I'll bring all this
together as part of the Equifax Cloud
Journey one of the core Foundation
platform that was envisioned by our
leadership was name data fabric what is
data fabric data fabric is our
Enterprise data management platform that
brings all our Equifax assets globally
into a common format so we
can U remove our silos that we had
across our data and we can fuel our
multi dat solutions that we really
wanted to do all year long all from the
beginning as our Equifax version so that
started um a little bit um around 2018
so we'll go a little deeper how we got
started but to understand the data
fabric let's look by some numbers just
the share scale right as Nel pointed out
early we already to the point have taken
250 billion data points and ingested
into this data management platform today
we have already enabled 2 billion plus
revenue of aquax across the
globe how did we do that let's talk
about the gke footprint which comes like
being we have close to 250 plus clusters
running we have across thousand plus
clusters running across Equifax so
that's sheer volume which we built on
the cloud native transformation journey
and putting all that together in
multi-year was a phenomenal Journey that
got us to this point this is just the
beginning let's talk a little bit more
understanding of a cloud native strategy
before and after picture what it was
before and how we are today hopefully
this helps you out on uh some of the
aspects how we decided to make um GK
Enterprise as our Conor
strategy so here are the few things that
uh we have taken the three important
aspects that really came down once we
decided as an architecture strategy to
move into Cloud native and all of our
compon all of our applications and
workloads are going to be rebuil um
using containers well once you get into
rebuilding all your applications into
containers then you land up into a Cloud
native architecture and GK becomes your
natural choice but before we were into
virtualized Cloud we all of our security
stack was hardening virtualized servers
patching those and when it came to cost
pretty much it was all amortized and
standard traditional infrastructure in
Equifax data center collocation that was
our footprint what did we do after is
really what we've been presenting is we
chose to be Cloud native we wanted our
Advanced analytic capab abilities to
fuel our next Innovation and really put
Security in front front like so that
it's not bolon but it's really from the
outset we have baked into our
sdlc that
said let's go a little bit on each of
the pillar the three pillars that are
always um important to fuel our growth
effective when I say effective what
really we needed is that when we were on
the journey to build our data fabric
platform we really need it to be
effective it has to meet our business
outcome the vision that our leadership
has set on so to do that we really had
to invest in GK Enterprise as our
Natural Choice to enable the scale that
we wanted as an Sr we wanted to build
run and manage as effective as possible
as safe as possible and as efficient as
possible so that we can meet our
business outcomes and we can focus on
that and the most critical piece is
doing at scale achieving the scale is
the harder part while we all understand
the three pillars but managing that at
scale is really the hard
one next pillar
safe if you have built something which
is effective but it's not safe it's not
going to cut it so bu taking care of
safe and building the security posture
and understanding all the controls
around it so we as Equifax uh we have
already open sort our Equifax control
framework which is built on industry
standard like Nest NCS benchmarks and on
top Equifax has its own regulated
controls that we have to we are
obligated for so that framework we kind
of has open sourced the policy but we
took those policies and codified and
automated as part of and it's bed into
our sdlc from the outset and we
continuously monitor our uh security
posture 24/7 so we know what's happening
and when the new threats new one lities
H happen we are always ahead of the game
and we are trying to continuously patch
and keep things
safe secure by
Design while effective and safe is
essential the second one or the third
pillar is being efficient that
said since we have our business has very
hard time managing the revenue growing
the revenue and they always on the toes
we have to stretch every single dollar
it's very business critical pillar that
we need to do I still remember like when
my business president talks to me he
says no matter what you do do not impact
my churching that's the revenue keep
your system up CFO would say if you have
spend the money we owe the money you got
to save the money before it leaves the
Equifax wall so that's the thing sorry
Google but we got to protect our dollars
so we have to stretch it so that's the
third pillar which is important to be
efficient in everything we do we monitor
our workload usage patterns our total
cost of ownership how we can
continuously move to a more efficient
Services as they've been available and
look towards
that that said that's a slice of our
Google Cloud journey of Equifax and I
hope you enjoyed the talk and got some
insights into our Progressive journey
and thank you and we'll ask n to be back
on the
stage thank you so much it's always
great to see some great insights and
real world examples of how the power of
some of the Innovation we are bringing
with that you're not off the hook yet we
have some questions for you all right um
honor Lisa could you please join us up
here
thanks yep it's always such a great
pleasure to hear about a customer story
stories like what weo is telling today
right so um actually I want to kick off
this QA session with a question of my
own to you weo um so for those in the
audience who are early in their
kubernetes or gke adoption Journey can
you share a few points that uh you wish
you knew uh when you just get
started um I think uh on the earlier
when we decided the architecture
strategy as Equifax being containers so
knowing the pitfall of the switches of
it and so that would be one I would say
understand your Cloud native
architecture study what your leaders
have said the vision and once you do
that then try to align with the strategy
so for us GK became the foundational
compute once we decided container is our
Cornerstone of the strategy the second
part I would say is keeping up uh with
observability this thing grows fast you
blink and it's like a kid they out in
school so uh I do think observability is
the next piece I would think uh really
invest early on it's very hard to solve
at the later part continuously think
about that as your journey is
progressing and the third and the most
important part um is the governance and
risk processes while you can uh automate
the security posture and all that if the
processes don't come along with it
automation only goes so far so I would
say that would be the third piece I
would invest on to learn more please
visit our launch Partners uh very
excited to share more details about it
and there are lots of more sessions so
please do visit them once again thank
you so much for your time thank
[Applause]
you